la crise financière sévit dans la france
entière et touche même un lieu jadis
symbole de l'opulence le château de
versailles le domaine royal est
aujourd'hui à l'économie et prend du
retard dans ses travaux initialement
prévus pour 2012 la dernière phase du
grand versa et démarrera au plus tôt en
2014 ce que nous faisons c'est que nous
différons le début de la seconde phase
de ces travaux parce qu'il nous a été
demandé comme à tous les établissements
publics un effort financier cette année
en raison de la crise inédite qui frappe
la france est donc en fonction de cette
crise et pour apporter notre
contribution exceptionnelle comme nous
l'a demandé le ministère de la culture
et bien nous reportons le début de ses
travaux de la deuxième phase le château
de versailles prendra en charge un tiers
du budget de cette ultime étape dont le
montant global s'élève à 171 millions
d'euros il attendra néanmoins les
subventions de l'état avant
d'entreprendre les travaux pour l'heure
d'établissement mène à bien la première
phase du projet pensé par l'architecte
dominique perrault à venir une
modification radicale de l'accueil des
visiteurs nous allons terminer la
première phase de schémas directeurs
avec la construction du pavillon dufour
et ce pavillon dufour comme vous savez
sera destiné en totalité à l'accueil du
public et au bien-être du public puisque
il y aura un salon t il y aura un
auditorium
catherine pégard président du château de
versailles depuis un an insiste il ne
s'agit pas d'abandon le grand versailles
est maintenu et l'offre culturelle
enrichie une nouvelle exposition vient
d'ailleurs d'être inauguré versailles et
l'antique à découvrir jusqu'en mars 2013